.
WE KNOW THAT THE DARKEST NIGHT
BECAUSE THE DAWN.
>> RUSSIA STATE MEDIA REPORTING
THE SITUATION IN THE KHERSON
REGION STABILIZING.
LESS FREQUENT ARTILLERY FIRE,
NO COUNTERATTACK FROM UKRAINIAN
FORCES.
CNN'S FRED PLANTED REPORTS NOW
FROM THE FRONT LINES.
>> ACROSS THE SEALS THAT THE
RUSSIANS, AND THAT MEANS WE
NEED TO GET INTO THE TRENCHES
THAT SNAKE THEIR WAY THROUGH
THE BATTLE SPACE IN SOUTHERN
UKRAINE.
>> THIS IS THE ACTUAL FRONT
LINE BETWEEN THE RUSSIANS AND
UKRAINIANS, THEY SAY THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE ONLY A COUPLE OF
KILOMETERS IN THAT DIRECTION
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
SHELLING THAT GOES ON HERE ON
THIS ALL THE TIME.
>> AND DESTROYED TANKS OUTSIDE
THE UKRAINIAN POSITION SHOWS
JUST HOW FIERCE THE FIGHTING IS
HERE.
SPENT CARTRIDGES FROM CLUSTER
BOMBS AND RUSSIAN FLAK VESTS
ALSO STILL LAYING AROUND.
WHILE SOME THOUGHT THAT THE
UKRAINIANS MIGHT QUICKLY OUST
THE RUSSIANS AND TAKE BACK THE
KEY CITY OF KHERSON, THE TRENCH
OF FEELING OF --
.
>> [INTERPRETER]
THERE ARE SHELLING EVERY DAY,
IN SOME PLACES LESS.
IN SOME MORE.
WE WOULD SHOOT BACK BUT WE HAVE
NOTHING TO SHOOT WITH HERE.
>> INSIDE THE MAIN HEADQUARTERS,
THE UN COMMANDER, WHO GOES BY
THE CARLSON --
, SHOWS ME THE GEAR THAT THEY
USED TO MONITOR THE RUSSIANS
MOVEMENTS AND COMMUNICATE WITH
THEIR OWN UNITS.
HE SAYS THAT THEY RESERVE THE
RUSSIANS STRENGTHENING THEIR
DEFENSIVE POSITIONS HERE.
>> [INTERPRETER]
I AM TALKING VERY WELL FOR THE
MOMENT.
AND WITHOUT EFFORT, WE ARE
ASSURING THEM THAT WE ARE
STRONGER.
AND PUSHING THEM BACK FROM OUR
TERRITORIES.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> THIS TERRITORY WAS ALL
RUSSIAN CONTROLLED, BUT NOW
UKRAINIAN TROOPS ARE INCHING
EVER CLOSER TO KHERSON.
HAVING TAKEN OUT MOST RUSSIANS
SUPPLY ROUTES ACROSS THE
MASSIVE DNIPRO RIVER, UKRAINE'S
PRESIDENT SAYS MOSCOW'S FORCES
NEED TO GET OUT OF THIS REGION.
OR RISK BEING BESIEGED.
>> THEY ARE NOT READY TO GO OUT
OF KHERSON.
BUT THEY KNOW THAT IT WILL BE,
IF WE WILL HAVE SUCCESS.
THEY WILL NOT HAVE POSSIBILITY
TO --
>> UKRAINE'S MILITARY IS
PUSHING RUSSIAN TROOPS BACK ON
SEVERAL FRONTLINES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND AS HIS COUNTRY
DISPLAYS CLEAR SIGNS OF
WEAKNESS, RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN RIPPING INTO THE
U.S. AND ITS ALLIES DURING A
SPEECH IN MOSCOW.
>> [INTERPRETER]
WELL DOMINATION IS WHAT THE
SO-CALLED WEST, THAT IT'S GAME
ON.
BUT THAT GAME IS WITHOUT A
DOUBT, A DANGEROUS, BLOODY, AND
I WOULD SAY FILTHY ONE.
>> BUT THE UKRAINIAN TROOPS IN
THE TRENCHES SAY THAT THEY ARE
RESISTING FOR THEIR OWN
COUNTRY'S SOVEREIGNTY AND HOPE
TO RETAKE MUCH OF THE KEY AREA
IN SOUTH UKRAINE BEFORE WINTER
SETS IN.
FRED PLEITGEN, CNN, IN THE
KHERSON REGION OF UKRAINE.
>> STEVE HALL IS OUR CNN
NATIONAL TV ANALYST, AND FORMER
CHIEF OF RUSSIA OPERATIONS FOR
THE CENTRAL INTELLIGENCE AGENCY,
THE CIA.
WELCOME BACK STEVE.
GOOD TO SEE.
YOU >> GET TO BE HERE.
>> I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO
THREE OF PUTIN'S STATEMENTS
FROM THURSDAY, MAYBE YOU CAN
TRANSLATE THE TRANSLATION AT
THE END, HERE'S SOUNDBITE
NUMBER ONE.
>> [INTERPRETER]
RUSSIA IS NOT CHALLENGING THE
WESTERN ALLIES.
RUSSIA'S JUSTICE OFFENDING ITS
WAY TO EXIST AND A FREE
DEVELOPMENT.
>> LITTLE BIT OF VICTIMHOOD IN
DELUSION THERE IT SEEMS LIKE,
GOVERNMENTS WHO IS ON THE USE
OF FUTURE WEAPONS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> [INTERPRETER]
WE NEVER INTENTIONALLY SAID
ANYTHING ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF USING NUCLEAR WEAPONS BY
RUSSIA.
WE'VE ONLY RESPONDED WITH HINTS
TO WESTERN LEADERS STATEMENTS.
>> JUST BECAUSE YOU SAY IT
DOESN'T MAKE IT TRUE, SOUNDBITE
NUMBER THREE ALMOST OUT OF
NOWHERE.
RUSSIA HAS A RIGHT TO BE
STRAIGHT?
>> [INTERPRETER]
THE WEST CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT WITH GAY PARADES, BUT THEY
SHOULDN'T DICTATE THE SAME
RULES FOR RUSSIA.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHICH QUESTION
THEY ARE ASSISTING ON PRIDE
WEEK IN MOSCOW, OR WHO WOULD
WANT TO GO BUT THIS CAN'T
SERIOUSLY BE HOW PUTIN SEES THE
WORLD?
>> NO I THINK WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE IS THAT WE HAVE MESSAGING
TO DIFFERENT AUDIENCES, SO
CERTAINLY THE FIRST AND I THINK
THE THIRD ARE CERTAINLY
DIRECTED PRIMARILY AT THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE AND THE DOMESTIC
AUDIENCE, THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF INTERNATIONAL AUDIENCE IN
THERE TOO BUT I THINK HIS
PRIMARY FOCUS HERE IS TO TRY TO
CONVINCE THE RUSSIANS ON THE
FIRST POINT FOR EXAMPLE THAT
RUSSIA IS SIMPLY DEFENDING
ITSELF, THIS OF COURSE DESPITE
THE WIDELY KNOWN FACT THAT IT
WAS RUSSIA WHO INVADED UKRAINE
AND NO ONE WAS INVADING RUSSIA,
SO THAT'S PRIMARILY A DOMESTIC
THING THAT I THINK IS DESIGNED
TO PUMP PEOPLE UP ON THESE
THINGS.
AS THEY CONTINUE TO GO BADLY IN
UKRAINE.
>> THAT LAST STAND BY THOUGH
ABOUT GAY PARADES, THAT BRINGS
US TO THIS MOVE BY THE RUSSIAN
PARLIAMENT.
TO EXPAND LAWS PROHIBITING GAY
PROPAGANDA.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE PROPOSE TO ESTABLISH A
BAN ON PROPAGANDA, OF
NONTRADITIONAL SEXUAL RELATIONS
OR PREFERENCES REGARDLESS OF
AGE.
>> THE SORT OF ANTI-GAY AGENDA
SEEMS TO WIN ITS WAY THROUGH
RUSSIA'S NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGY.
WHO SHOULD BE PROTECTED AND
FROM WHITE, NOW THERE'S A RACE
TO THIS INTERNATIONAL LEVEL AND
THIS HOMOPHOBIA MASQUERADING AS
FOREIGN POLICY?
>> YEAH, IT'S REALLY
FASCINATING.
BECAUSE AGAIN THERE'S A LOT OF
RESOLUTIONS INSIDE OF RUSSIA.
I SAY TO MYSELF.
THERE IS A LOT OF RESONANCE
INSIDE OF RUSSIAN SOCIETY
AGAINST ANYTHING HAVING TO DO
WITH, THERE IS A LOT OF
DISCRIMINATION OF WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT THIS IS AN INTERESTING
THING BECAUSE WHEN HE RAISES IT,
THERE IS NOW A NEW
INTERNATIONAL AUDIENCE WHICH I
WOULD ARGUE, A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO, DID NOT EXIST.
THIS IS NOT JUST THE FAR RIGHT
WING OF THE UNITED STATES,
THESE ARE THE VIKTOR ORBAN'S OF
THE WORLD, THESE ARE THE VERY
CONSERVATIVE, POPULIST
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE POPPING UP
IN NATO COUNTRIES, IN THE WEST,
AND THIS POPULIST MOVEMENT
WHICH IS OFTENTIMES MUCH MORE
CULTURALLY TRADITIONAL AND ALSO
UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT THINGS LIKE
THE GAY MOVEMENT AND BEING GAY.
SO THERE IS ALSO AN
INTERNATIONAL AUDIENCE TO THAT
PARTICULAR ARGUMENT ALTHOUGH
HOW IT RELATES TO UKRAINE'S A
LITTLE STRANGE.
>> YEAH, IT ALL SOUNDS KIND OF
A LITTLE STRANGE.
PUTIN ADDED THIS PREDICTION FOR
GOOD MEASURE.
HERE HE IS.
>> [INTERPRETER]
WE ARE STANDING IN THE
HISTORICAL FRONT HERE, AHEAD IS
THE MOST DANGEROUS,
UNPREDICTABLE AND AT THE SAME
TIME THE MOST IMPORTANT DECADES
SINCE THE END OF WORLD WAR II.
>> WHY?
BECAUSE IN THE PAST THERE SEEMS
TO BE THIS PERCEPTION THAT
PUTIN, YES HE IS --
BUT RUSSIA HAD THE APPEARANCE
OF MOVING TOWARDS A DEMOCRACY,
THOSE, PARLIAMENTARY VOTE, THAT
KIND OF STUFF.
NOW IT SEEMS THAT IT'S JUST
GOTTEN OUT OF HAND AND HE DOES
SEEM TO BE KIND OF CRAZY?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, THERE'S VERY
FEW THINGS THAT I AGREE WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN ABOUT, BUT THAT
STATEMENT JUST TAKEN AS THAT
STATEMENT IS INDEED THE TRUE
FACT.
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS IN THE
WORLD ARE GONNA BE VERY
INTERESTING AND VERY DANGEROUS,
THEY'RE DANGEROUS THOUGH
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE VLADIMIR
PUTIN WHO SEEMINGLY.
WE GET BACK TO THE GAY QUESTION
AND OTHER NON TRADITIONAL PARTS
OF SOCIETY, IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE ABLE TO TRUST HIS OWN
POPULIST, HIS OWN PEOPLE OR
PEOPLE ELSEWHERE IN THE WORLD
TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS AND
NOW OF COURSE THAT'S GONNA COME
AS NO SURPRISE TO RUSSIANS, THE
SOCIAL CONTRACT AND RUSSIA IS
DIFFERENT THAN IN MANY PLACES
WHERE RUSSIA GIVES UP A GREATER
AMOUNT OF THEIR FREEDOMS AND
EXCHANGE FOR WHAT PUTIN REFERS
TO AS STABILITY.
BUT, YEAH IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS IT'S GONNA BE INTERESTING
BECAUSE WHAT PUTIN IS TRYING TO
DO IS CHALLENGE WHAT HE SEES AS
WESTERN DOMINANCE IN THE WORLD
TODAY.
>> YEAH, IT WILL BE DANGEROUS
AND CHALLENGING BECAUSE OF THE
STUFF THAT HE IS DOING AND TO
TRY TO WALK IT BACK SAYING, THE
WHOLE THING WAS A CLOSED
CIRCULAR RE-LOOP OF CRAZY TO
ME.
>> IT'S A VERY INTERESTING
THING THAT'S COMING OUT AND
SOMEONE PUT IT INTERESTING
CLEAR AS THE MIRRORING EFFECT,
WHAT HE WILL DO IS HE WILL
UNDERTAKE ACTIVITIES ATTACKING
AND ANNEXING AND NEIGHBORING
COUNTRY TRYING TO KEEP CERTAIN
SECTORS OF HIS OWN POPULIST
DOWN AND UNDER CONTROL AND YET
WHAT HE DOES IS TURN AROUND AND
SAY THIS IS REALLY WHAT THE
WEST IS DOING WE HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH ANY OF THOSE SO T